this is really good news and especially
coming after Columbus Day you know
Columbus Day is one of my favorite
holidays Christopher Columbus much
maligned uh the American left was too
busy uh sing for Hamas this year to
engage in their usual attacks on
Christopher Columbus one of the great
men of history who helped to found our
entire civilization in the new world uh
but and and a wonderful product of the
old world too and a a great devout
Catholic and just a a very impressive
man who made it across the ocean blue
with dead reckoning in his own grit and
prayers and Faith uh
but I I was off on Columbus Day I like
the idea of taking Columbus Day off okay
I like the idea of acknowledging this
good man and this good
holiday there's some good news as the
statues have been falling for years and
years and they malign Columbus with the
same arguments that you hear from the
pramas side and the BLM side and antifa
in the left they say he was a
colonizer he was an imperialist he was
was a white man he was bad he was just
he was Catholic Oh it's the worst thing
he's cath oh no uh well we hear all of
that in recent years one little town in
Providence decided to put a statue back
up or one little town in Rhode Island
not Providence put a statue back up that
would be uh Johnston Memorial Park in
Johnston Memorial Park in Johnston Rhode
Island they took a statue that had been
taken down in idence and they moved it
over to this town and they put it back
up this was thanks to Providence former
Providence mayor Joe poino good son of
Italy who purchased the old statue and
brought it over to this nice town why is
this such a great story it's such a
great story not because we're all going
to take trips to Johnston Rhode Island
though maybe we should not because it's
not a bad thing that the bigger towns in
the bigger cities Providence and all
over the even New York wants to take
these statues down
it's not that not that we've made it out
of the woods that they're going to keep
their statues up but it means
that we can restore things we don't need
to just shrug our shoulders and aede to
the the left's absolute destruction of
our
civilization the the lib cities want to
take down the Columbus statues the
conservative towns can put them back up
the lib cities want to take away
parents' rights the conservative towns
can say come on over here if you want to
raise your kids
the cons the liberal cities want to
enshrine the rainbow flag
and the conservative towns can say we're
not going to tolerate that here we
got and if you're an adult and you talk
to kids about weird sex stuff you're
going to get arrested and if you are an
adult and you try to put some weird
obscene material into schools and
libraries you're going to get
arrested we can do that no antifa is not
there tearing that statue down in John
Rhode Island not just yet you could do
it in your town too hope is not lost we
can return we're not going to go back in
time we're going to keep going forward
in time but we can turn toward the right
direction right now go to Jus cell.com
noes everyone here at the office loves
the genus C Dark Spot Corrector you
might be asking what this product even
does well if you have sunspots dark
spots discoloration or dry skin the
genus Cell Dark Spot Corrector will help
those blemishes disappear Kimberly from
Youngstown Ohio says quote my appearance
has improved so much since using genus
cell I love all my genus cell products
and my skin looks younger now it's your
turn to feel like Kimberly but hurry
because this sale is ending very soon
take advantage of genus's most popular
package which includes the Beloved Dark
Spot Corrector this package also
includes Jus cell's classic under eye
treatment you will get all of these
products from a 70% off genus cell so
confident in their products you can try
them yourself completely risk-free if
you don't see immediate results you will
get your money back it's simple go to
Jus cell.com
K wle start looking years even decades
younger tomorrow say hello to the very
best skin that you've ever had at Jus
cell.com that is jus.com
big story in the LA Times black people
are fleeing the United States because of
the oppression and the colonialism and
the imperialism and the ism and the
racism and the
ismism America does not deserve serve me
why black people are leaving the United
States says the LA Times now because
this is the LA times I have a good hunch
going into this article that whatever it
says is not true but here's what the
article
says filmmaker Jamila nedine was locked
down in La during the pandemic watching
as the nation convulsed in protest over
the murder of George Floyd when she had
an epiphany America does not deserve me
as a black woman Nori Dean always tried
to work twice as hard as those around
her thinking if I'm smart enough pretty
enough successful enough then finally
people will treat me as a human being
but she grieved yet another unarmed
black man killed by police she decided
she was done trying to prove herself to
a society that she felt would never
really love her back so nor Dean 39
packed her bags and left she now spends
her days working for us clients in Chic
cafes in the Caribbean leading healing
ceremonies at a local waterfall and
trying to figure out who she is exactly
outside of an American context it's like
leaving an abusive relationship she said
of exiting the United States okay lot in
there but the major claim is black
people are fleeing the United States
because of racism and Injustice and that
is just not true and here's how I know
for a fact that that's not
true how many what was the net move
movement of black people into and out of
the United States over the last say 20
years
roughly 3 million into the United States
not out it wasn't a mass Exodus it was
people moving
in 2 million from Africa 1 million from
the Caribbean they moved into they
immigrated into the United why would
they immigrate into the United States if
America is terribly racist and evil and
unjust and racist cops go around
slaughtering black black men innocent
people all the time why would they do
that because they know that that's not
true because they know that it's
actually pretty good in the United
States for black people and for most
other people because they know that not
only will they not have trouble getting
a
job because of the color of their skin
they know that they'll have extra help
getting a job because of the color of
their skin not only will they not have a
harder time getting into college because
of the color of their skin they'll have
an easier time getting into college
because of the color of their skin
because we have not only de facto but de
Ure racial discrimination in the United
States on behalf of black people and
Hispanic people to a lesser degree and
against white people and Asian people to
a lesser degree that has technically
been struck down in recent months
because the Supreme Court uh struck down
affirmative action in college admissions
but the college is all just admitted
they're just going to figure out a way
to hide it now and they they'll hide it
in the personal statement
just just completely made up but this
narrative the reason I bring it up this
narrative which we we know you know I'm
skeptical of Statistics but certain
statistics like how many people come in
how many people go out are pretty
solid uh at least when it comes to Legal
immigration illegal immigration the
Biden Administration is a little weaker
on but un legal immigration it's pretty
clear black people are coming into the
United States we we can know for a fact
that that is the behavior and yet this
narrative prevails and the narrative is
very very powerful that narrative burned
down half the country for about eight
months during the George Floyd
riots that narrative
shapes many many people not just black
people it shapes the views of white
liberals it shapes the views of all
sorts of people all sorts of liberal
people who are mistaken but those
mistaken ideologies can have horrific
effects and impel people to do very very
terrible
things that's what you're seeing in this
campaign for decolonization
which is which is aiming toward we saw
it over the weekend proof positive we
saw it in the endorsements of BLM it is
aiming toward violence against civilians
against men women children and little
babies they want to come kill us because
they've convinced themselves of a bogus
narrative even if that historical
narrative were true and it's not it
still would not justify their actions
there is no moral or ethical
justification for the targeting of
civilians they don't know that these are
very very confused people and what's
very dangerous is not just that they're
confused it's a fallen world and people
have defects of intellect and will
what's dangerous is that narrative has
been pushed by the most elite segments
of our country in the media in Academia
in government
in entertainment everywhere everywhere
and so it's taken hold doesn't
necessarily matter that it's not true it
can have real effects in the world boy
what a great clip that was now hey hey
hey hey hey ring that Bell subscribe to
the Michael NS Channel we'll see you
next time